just the air time you know to feel that
the float it's that fine edge of being
like terrifying at the same boat that's
so exhilarating and there are moments
where it's really scary at the San
Francisco school of circus arts
everything is always up in the air the
roller boy is kind of like riding a
bicycle and it seems really awkward at
first but after a while you have a lot
of control and you can even make it look
harder
that really is only at a circus school
will you be put through hoops
wrapped around poles and practically
turned inside out come back through some
of the tricks take years to perfect
although I have lots of tricks under my
belt I keep practicing them just to make
sure that I still have them to make sure
they're there it's like if you don't
work it you lose it
some people are better suited to certain
tricks due to their physical makeup
some people have stronger legs they
might be a tumbler stronger arms they
might do aerial or climbing poles or
something circus acrobatics is not just
about strength and coordination the most
vital element is
Trust took me places I couldn't believe
I was going mental
early affects the physical if you don't
believe you can do something then you
can't and also if you don't instill
confidence in yourself you're not gonna
instill it in your partner right here
yep
and take your left foot all the way up
to my left shoulder you have to work
together a lot I wind up holding a lot
of people up and they have to trust me
and I have to trust that they're gonna
do what we've already rehearsed for the
california-based new pickle circus
daredevil stunts are all in a day's work
for the performers the attraction is
about more than just pleasing the
audience what is it about it sounds like
it's in your blood or so I think there's
two things I think one thing is
performing on stage is such an
adrenaline rush it's just phenomenal the
other thing is working in a physical
realm but working with people instead of
against people so everything has to do
with trust not about competition is what
you depend on yep in the circus the only
person you're competing with is yourself
especially in the ultimate test of
courage the flying trapeze just getting
to the platform is scary there you go
almost to heaven all right
any prayers before you go okay it's a
leap of faith okay here we go
ready hep feet together
[Applause]
we were inches from a handoff but not
this time
okay it's a little she signed me checks
right now but that's a very good